hello and welcome to the new playing
vash cool battle school I know with the
black pieces so in the Queens gambit
accepted what is he going to play yeah
this is a head earlier like a couple of
games perform and in this game
white fell right into some trap with
Queen b3 not this time okay so no night
before was bad right Queen a four nights
is six is probably not working
[Music]
you think queen bee 7 queen bee so hmm
did I do this right
couldn't be 7 Knight b6 I think this is
okay but can be Sam Knight b6 p should
be too can I trap it really can trip the
Queen
[Music]
hmm yeah this is something that where I
think I shouldn't know it rather than
find it and I'm not knowing it I have to
find it
so a pawn takes Queen to between takes
b7 takes c4 it takes a 8 then I got to
check well that is a very strong
compensation it's a very strong
compensation Bishop d2 I take check
deform that's killing already so he has
to go King f1 and then I am Bishop d3 at
least which will tie a white down quite
a bit
really ok
[Music]
I wonder if I should just castle warm
play Bishop d3 I mean it all looks
completely terrible for white Quincy
five four come on I mean I don't have to
meet him Amir Lee my positional
compensation is so you Jim it's not
necessary to win Amir limb he's never
getting the King into safety as the
problem never okay this Bishop is
attacked
I would like to play something more
aggressive
yeah then just moving it back
of course I can just put it on to be six
just to be six that's not bad at all now
I just need Knight to d5 and then what
Knight b6 now tragic what do I take
first okay let's go Knight b6 it's I'm
on 13 seconds so it's important to keep
that in mind
now what white is not going to survive
this I'm going to make that prediction
maybe I'm screwing it up timewise or
something but just the position you that
that that you cannot survive
this is too much the rook is hanging
Queen e2 c2 and resigns am that's was
not possible to play I think I'm the
compensation that I got there out of
this opening was too much this is a
tricky opening line I wasn't quite
certain after Knight c3 what I should do
night before it's definitely interesting
but I thought maybe mistakenly that he
has this a 35 here is a problem and this
is this is refuted by a6 of almost a six
and that was beyond my powers I mean I
do understand it once you see it you do
understand it so a six and if he takes
now the check is happening that was
clear anyway and now King f1 b5 and
explosion the problem is you cannot even
do this this is made in one yeah and if
you do this takes the Queen cannot take
because I'm winning it immediately so
it's a complete disaster I didn't see a
six this was my problem I thought here I
don't have a good reply I only saw the
check and then I didn't know what to do
I mean I can take this but he takes and
this is a mess so I didn't do it and I
played c6 but so but not before then was
was a good move
okay c6 this and E six still I'm happy
here I think this is a good position if
he takes here Knight b6 is interesting I
felt we should be too and then probably
just queen takes d4 something like this
is probably fine yeah only recently
looked at this it should be fine so he
took on d5 and now both captures come
into consideration but I like this
because it allows Queen b7 which i think
is super dangerous at least so he took
this I grabbed him and now King e2 was a
huge blunder King f1 is better yeah
that's you Ivan actually I expected this
and thought that I'm not sure if I
should give the check so I give the
check and I cancel that was my thinking
and I thought here I mean my
compensation must be very strong he has
a very hard time to get his pieces
sorted you know this is pretty awkward
so it must be a really good play and in
practical play I would definitely want
to have black but maybe the engine is
correct with currently giving equal but
this
something where a little bit of depth in
calculation can make a huge difference
because this is not an initiative and a
tech that is like happening right away
and I switch the engine only and for
deeper depth and it's now on 0.64 like
I'm not surprised that this should be
better for black just by general
considerations okay he played this
Bishop d3 not the best okay but it's
hard to believe that he's surviving this
now Knight e3 was wrong okay here f5 was
strong f5 threatening f4 mate and
probably this is the thing I take okay I
get it
and after 97 rook t1 leads to a playable
position for white okay he gets to
sacrifice it back am i computer is on
equal at the moment now I'm not sure
maybe
I mean I'm two pawns down but the king
is still running around in the open
night before king e2 night C to assess
the line and now Bishop g5
okay yeah so this was a big mistake I
should have played f5 okay Bishop d2 and
now everything is back in order again t3
double question mark okay
it's so wins comfortably I have to be
thrilled
It's Made but okay you don't you don't
defend this it's just not possible the
immediate idea is to take and play rook
c8 and what do you do let's give white
some some moves I don't know
anyways that looks funky but just just
random move some Queen takes and rook c8
you're not surviving this Knight c3 or
all this I don't know it doesn't it
doesn't feel like you can you can
survive it yeah this Bishop f5 line is a
tricky thing I have to remember this
though that night before is an option
here okay guys thanks for watching